the private sector does not have
monopoly on competence in fact one of
the things that was discovered by Steve
Goldsmith when he looked at he first ran
for mayor as a privatization advocate
and in the end became an advocate for
competition because he found that the
public sector employees very often and
their management systems could beat the
private sector in a fair competition
when they didn't have political
patronage holding them back and we
didn't have over-regulated
administrative processes holding them
back and by freeing them up very often
he found that they did in fact hold
their own quite nicely sometimes they
knew the situation better they do the
equipment better they knew the community
better and sometimes that's an important
variable but just the same the make or
Bali decision is an increasingly
important part of managing every
organization because we are in a global
economy and because of Technology
communications technology and
information technology where you used to
have to have everything close at hand in
order to be productive now in fact you
don't have to be you can purchase things
from other places you can purchase
expertise from other places and also
because of the technical content of much
work very often even something that you
think you can do by yourself you end up
needing help on of one sort or another
in a world that's more and more driven
by brainpower and expertise it's often
the case that you need to find other
people to help you so that is actually
what I wanted to talk to you about which
is why contract management and
outsourcing is important what are the
central elements of this is a management
tool the knowledge of manager needs in
order to manage contracts and
contractors the obstacles to contracting
which which we saw in the case when
should you and should you not contract
and though it's when is it a good time
to make the buy decision and when should
you avoid it and what's the future of
this so we'll talk about that and then
we'll
talk a little bit about the final exam
why is contract management important
well this is the fundamental vertically
integrated organizations are being
replaced by organizational networks the
story I often tell and I'm sure I
mentioned it here before this if you
look at the Ford Motor Company in the
beginning of the 20th century it's the
classic example of the vertically
integrated company Ford owned iron mines
coal mines and they made steel they
owned rubber plantations and tired
factories and they made tires they made
virtually every element every part of
the Model T was made somewhere by Ford
they had their own advertising agency
trucks to ship the cars and dealerships
everything from the moment of creation
until you're driving the Model T off of
the showroom floor was controlled by
Ford in a huge vertically integrated
company what's the problem with that in
the short run when technology isn't that
great we could close this door over here
in the short run when technology isn't
great and you don't have some of the
things that we have today like cell
phones and computers and the Internet
you need to assemble all the things for
production in one place there's
otherwise you get on the assembly line
to make your car and it stops because
you run out of something and so you
don't want to run out of anything and
the only way to make sure of that before
we have a good road system or
transportation system or communication
system is to assemble at nearby and that
led to the kind of vertical integration
that you see in fourth button here's
what happens as time goes on then
General Motors comes along in General
Motors doesn't own their own steel
company they buy steal from us steel us
steel can make steel cheaper then GM
could or that for did and so Ford is
already then working at a competitive
disadvantage because a company whose
distinctive competence the only thing it
did was make steel could make better and
cheaper steel than the car company that
made steel kind of as a sideline and
then as the components of the car become
more complicated and we have more of a
road system and we have more of the
technology being adopted by other places
suddenly Ford finds themselves in a
competitive disadvantage by the company
that was only focusing on the few things
that it did well okay did the design of
the car the marketing of the car the
assembly of the car and maybe even
making a few of the parts but certainly
not all of them and so that is is in
essence how networked organizations have
been replacing vertically integrated
organizations and this is happening this
is why this is the logic of the global
economy because you know everybody
laughs about well maybe the call center
is located somewhere in India but maybe
that's a good idea because the people in
that community run good call centers
okay and maybe the distinctive
competence of New York City may in fact
be that we can assemble a diverse group
of people here from all over the world
in brain industries because it's a fun
and interesting place to live and it's
not that hard to get to and it's a
reasonably taller in place and lately
it's been crime relatively crime free
okay so every organization every place
has the thing that it specializes in in
the emerging global economy and the way
this what allows us to happen is
advances in communication shipping and
transportation technology you know when
new york city was an industrial city
okay the west side of manhattan was
filled with docs if you ever see the
movie on the waterfront you see
stevedores and they're literally
carrying boxes off of ships well that
isn't how it's done anymore now you have
to go to New Jersey where somebody
operates a crane and takes the container
off the ship and it becomes the
back of a truck or the back are part of
a train okay that in and of itself
radically changed the geography of New
York City because we couldn't fit that
stuff in here anymore and even if we
could you can make more money selling
apartments and having high-end stores in
Manhattan than having printing presses
automobile factories or clothing
factories and so increasingly you see
this change and it's all part of an
emerging global economy and it makes
contracting out a part of this overall
picture now for a manager what this
means is a lot of the work that you
manage the stuff you need for your work
is done by people outside of your
organization you're accountable for that
work but it's not directly underneath
your control the the point about
contracting out is you have to develop
skills that you didn't think you needed
particularly skills and making sure that
the services that you get fit your needs
so what are the central themes then of
contract management what do you have to
do what does a contract manager need to
do the first thing is you got to figure
out what are these contractors doing how
do they do their work how do I motivate
them how do I make them do the things
that I need them to do okay I need to
create then a system of contractor
incentives some of it's money some of it
is other things the same things that
Matt that that inspire other people but
the other thing you have to do is you
have to know what they're doing how do
you track the performance of an
organization that you're not part of so
you have to write in your contract the
right to find out what the organization
is doing or in the case in the case we
heard earlier today we're we're one of
the group's said we need to have a third
party firm coming here in ordered
performance well you have to get the
right to do that it has to be in your
contract that you're allowed to do that
you write your contract poorly and you
send your auditor there and they say oh
no we're not showing you our stuff it's
all proprietary goodbye so it has to be
in the contract the other thing of
contract manager has to do is get a good
price and how do you
what the price should be now if I used
to make the stuff then I kind of know
what it ought to cost but if I've never
bought this stuff before how do I know
you know what's the good price of a you
know of a piece of equipment or of a
service how much does it cost to pick up
the garbage or to clean the apartment at
night who knows well you need to figure
that out and that requires the manager
to learn things about the operation
that's contracted out you need to also
understand the rules governing
purchasing and the government there's a
lot of rules but you know a Columbia
University there are enormous number of
rules most large organizations have
rules on purchasing why they don't want
you selling to your brother your brother
Fred who then kicks back ten percent to
you okay no I know it's a shock to some
of you because that's how you've been
doing business your whole career but in
fact that's the purchasing dries
purchasing agents crazy you have to know
something about the network you're
contracting with who's good who's bad at
it who's corrupt who's competent who
knows how to do this and sometimes
you're contracting for something that
hasn't been done before you know so I
work for a company that's been that's
been involved in contracting with coned
on energy efficiency services and this
company is delivering a service that
Conrad's never contracted for and
believe me they're having a lot of
trouble figuring out how to manage this
contractor because it doesn't fit into
their usual practice of what they manage
that they are better at managing their
vendors that provide them with the
supplies they need than with these
particular services you need to know
something about the culture the
motivation the track record of the
contractor so it's not a turnkey
operation like the Mayor of Atlanta
wanted to see with the water system the
acts I have to know quite a bit to buy
something but think about when you go
and buy a car okay I mean this is a
obviously we all make the bodice in here
none of us here I think are making cars
anybody here may ever make a car there
are people that do that I know but I
don't so I have to go by now what's the
problem when I'm when I'm buying a car
well first I know nothing
about cars and it's obvious by the cars
I bought and the price I get and the
reliability of what I buy okay because I
don't know anything about it I go in
there and they give me a whole song and
dance and I have no knowledge of what's
going on in front of me okay obviously I
don't think it's that important I live
in Manhattan I don't to drive that much
okay but the point is to be an effective
purchaser or something you want to know
something about it you need to have
resources and analyses of what makes a
good car the same thing is true of a
contractor so let's talk about the
obstacles to contracting and how they
overcome because there's a whole bunch
of problems in buying stuff okay you
know one of them is the ignorant buyer
which I just talked about but then you
have when you are buying something and
you want competitive bidding you issue
what's called a request for proposal or
you put out to the world in one form or
another a set of requirements saying bid
on this tell me what you can what you
can provide for this what happens when
you don't know what you want to buy well
what happens if nobody knows in other
words sometimes when the military for
example is developing a new weapon
system they actually contract to develop
the specifications for the later
contracts because they don't know what
they're trying to buy okay so solutions
to this problem or you can create what's
called a mission contract a very large
general contract and as you learn what
you need you write specific task orders
against the contract or you can try a
pilot project a small set of contracts
may be a few competing projects to learn
to try to figure out what do we need to
buy here okay so those are ways around
that particular problem sometimes you
have cumbersome contracting procedures
where it takes a long time to buy
something and so sometimes what you have
to do is use an existing contract and
try to squeeze your purchase into that
of course I'm what you could do is work
to streamline the procedure
try to figure out a more effective way
to buy but very often you find it even
buying something can be very difficult
sometimes you find that you put
something out for bid and nobody bids
okay or only one company bids and if
only one company bids then you've got a
monopoly situation and that may tell you
that this particular service should not
be contracted out because there aren't
enough bidders for you to really get a
good price there is no competition it's
too specialized and maybe you need to
figure out a different way of getting
that service provided maybe you have to
develop your own capacity in house
because you really can't buy it and
you'll often see that with new
technologies where there isn't anybody
available to do that a lot of the issues
around a green building and solar
technology is a shortage of installers
of people that know how to do that work
and so sometimes if you need it you
actually have to send somebody to school
to figure out how to make it happen
another obstacle is poor communication
between the buyer and the vendor and we
saw this in Atlanta okay we're in the
end all organizational relationships
come down to informal human
relationships no matter what the
contract says no matter what the no
matter what the legal language says is
this a good working relationship do I
have a friend in the other company does
do I have somebody on my staff who at
least hangs out with somebody on their
staff that can provide communication and
really figure out what needs to be done
here to make stuff happen and then also
we need informal communication in the
process of bringing about this
contracted function in other words once
you let the contract it's not a turnkey
operation now we have to have meetings
together now we have to have lunch
together you know occasionally we have
to do retreats together what we really
work together as a team because
otherwise the the activity that you're
contracting out will fall apart you need
clear milestones and performance
measures that to be clear what you're
buying what is it we're buying when is
do what's the definition of quality very
often a vendor doesn't know what you're
asking for and so a problem in
contracting out is you've never really
explained what you're looking for
sometimes because you don't know okay
and sometimes it's also because people
in both organizations are afraid to talk
they interact with each other at the
field level and they know that there's
something wrong but they're afraid to
tell the boss because there's always to
shoot the messenger issue so
communication between buyer and vendors
important sometimes the problem is
inadequate direction from the purchaser
to the vendor sometimes is because the
purchaser has conflicting objectives one
part of the company or the organization
wants one thing another part wants
another thing and instead of just
instead of settling this agreement they
make their conflicting demands on the
contractor and that portion has to
figure out how to reconcile these
competing demands sometimes its
political sometimes the political
struggle in the purchasing organization
is settled by who gets to buy something
and so the the vendor again is a
political pawn in the battle between
competing forces in the organization
that happens in the private sector as
much as it happens in the public sector
politics is not limited to the
government I mean I know a lot of you
know that because you work in private
companies and you know about the
politics that are there and there is a
there is of course a there's a rule
about politics which is that the level
of conflict is usually an inverse ratio
to the stakes so the least important
things get the most intense conflict and
conflict and politics is in every
organization is the famous statement you
know dwight eisenhower was the president
of Columbia University after he left
NATO just before he ran for president
united states and during his
announcement press conference one of the
one of the questions the press asked is
why you leaving academia for the for the
political world and run for president
and he said I was hoping for a job as a
little less political and being
president of the University so if you
think that politics is limited to the
government it's not the case sometimes
this inadequate direction is because the
organization that's purchasing is really
poorly managed we certainly saw this in
Atlanta that you saw a problem of the
vendor not being able to get clear
direction and so a lot of the problems
in contract management or in contractor
performance is really reflection of the
organization doing the purchasing
they've got problems and they just pass
it along to the companies that they're
working for sometimes what happens is
the contractor gives an organization's
work a low priority and this happens
when you know if you think about the
structure let's take a typical
consulting firm now anybody who worked
for consulting firm ok so in consulting
firms most of the the resources in the
most of the the incentives go to people
that bring in business okay those are
the rainmakers in fact a friend of mine
once divided the consulting world into
three parts he said there's finders
minders and grinders the finders of the
rainmakers the people of fine business
the minders of the project management
and the grinders are people with recent
master's degrees that do all the work
okay and so if all of the incentives in
the company are delivered to the people
that bring in business then you're going
to have a lot of people that are good at
getting business but maybe not so good
at performing once the business is one
and you see that very often in
organizations that may have a lot of
flash and a lot of good sales but not so
good at performance and so what do you
do well first of all you develop
contract mechanisms to make sure you get
performance reviews milestones sanctions
sanctions can work pretty well as can
incentives you know the there's lots of
examples particularly in in road
construction and things like that where
if the if the road repair is done faster
every week you get it done
schedule you make a little extra money
every week you're behind schedule you
lose a little bit of your feet and those
kinds of incentives do have an impact
the other thing is you can publicize
contractor failures if a contractor
doesn't perform and you're in the
government you can make sure people know
about it if you're in the private sector
you can make sure people know about it
these this firm is not reputable
sometimes the contractor tries to
lowball performance they're trying to
squeeze every dollar out of the contract
and so they're not giving the latest
equipment or the well-trained staff to
perform those tests what do you do well
first of all you can audit and you can
have penalty and cancellation clauses if
you see that what you're asking for
isn't happening sometimes there's
political opposition to the idea of
contracting sometimes it's just people
inside the organization don't want to
have an outside vendor involved in it
because they want to keep the jobs to
themselves or their friends or the old
way of doing things so that can be part
of it and certainly in in a unionized
environment you sometimes see a
resistance to outsourcing because it's
seen as a way of busting the Union and
one way around that is that is to insist
in the contract that the Union that the
contracted service is also unionized and
that can get around that particular
argument if that becomes important
sometimes you have political or senior
management interference in contractor
selection they have their favorite firm
maybe they're getting a little piece on
the side and they want to make sure you
pick that contractor so that has to be
resisted I think that the issue of
corruption in purchasing and contracting
out really needs to be understood as a
rule of thumb i should say that whether
you're in the public private and
nonprofit sector you know it's a
slippery slope you know a bottle of
scotch at christmas is suddenly a fancy
dinner is suddenly a trip to the bahamas
in the private jet of the corporation
and so on and so forth and before you
know it you're on the take and so
there's a very simple way to deal with
that which is to always resist just say
no don't take the present return it
gracefully and gratefully say thank you
for the scotch but I'm not allowed to
accept these kinds of things no matter
what you're in whatever business you're
in be very careful about that it can
create the reality the appearance of
impropriety it's worth resisting I say
it's often a subject of exit voice or
loyalty there's a as a book public
sector book by a fellow named Albert
Hirschman called exit voice and loyalty
and in the book it deals with the
question what do i do when i'm told to
do something that I think is wrong and I
work at an organization so he says that
you have three options you can exit say
i'm leaving i'm not going to be a part
of this you could decide that it's so
important I have to be a whistleblower
and go public that's the voice option or
you can say you know in the grand scheme
of things I don't like this but it's not
unethical I'll go along with it I'll be
loyal to the organization and we'll live
to fight another day so those are the
three options when you're faced with
unethical behavior whether it's
contracting or anything else there's a
fourth one I've written about which is
called guerilla warfare which is you
very quietly within the organization
fight things but that I think there's
also a slippery slope I kind of like the
exit voice and loyalty formulation
although people do the guerrilla warfare
all the time another obstacle to
contracting is poor performance
measurement systems the measures of what
the contractors doing or measuring the
wrong thing or the collection system or
the analysis system or the reporting
system of those data is also inadequate
and so you can find that that's a
problem with contracting you can't
contract something if you don't know
what's going on so without a good data
system you can't tell whether the
contractor is performing or not so you
have to specify this in the contract you
can specify the indicator the way it's
collected how you get it and how its
audited
okay because if an unaudited performance
measurement system is a work of fiction
and so you want in contracting it's even
more important because these people
don't work for you now you always have
the option of ending the contract so
it's not like you have no power you can
always say okay I'll wait till this
contracts over and we'll get a new
contractor but meanwhile you're getting
crummy service sometimes you have
insufficient auditing of performance
measures and so I'm just made this point
I won't go over it again except to say
that that there's always a way to check
on the accuracy of information and if
you don't check on it you should assume
it's not accurate sometimes you have
inadequate incentive provisions or
misdirected ones you need to link in
every organizational relationship the
people and the other organization have
to have a reason for giving you what you
need that reason can be money it can be
repeat business it can be a variety of
other things but incentives in
organizational behavior are always
central and they're no less central in a
contracted relationship sometimes you
have conflict of interest issues which I
mentioned before which is to say that in
both government or in the nonprofit
sector and the private sector sometimes
you may find yourself in a purchasing
situation with a company run by somebody
that you know or your financial interest
in or your wife knows or your brother
knows or is your brother and in all of
those cases if you're a decision-maker
in those situations you have to recuse
yourself and say I have a conflict of
interest here I'm not going to
participate in this you guys do that
okay it's extremely important to do this
and this is also reason why contracts
that are decided by panels are often
better than contract decisions made by
individuals there's in a panel there's a
certain amount of transparency and
visibility at least within the
organization it can still be
confidential to the outside world but
within the organization the decisions
can be made by more than one person a
union opposition to contracting I
mentioned
the other issue is you know there's a
lot of attention in the media to
privatization and contractor failures is
you know one of the things we're seeing
right now in this cutback environment to
somehow contractors are all wasteful
every contract is wasteful could always
be done cheaper by people inside now
this issue of competence and price is
not an issue related to the make or buy
decision sometimes it's cheaper to do it
in-house sometimes it's cheaper to
contract it out sometimes it's more
competent if you do it in-house
sometimes you can get more competent
people on the outside it is not a
function of whether it's a
public-private internal or external
organization this is really a fallacy
that has very little to do with
organizational analysis and everything
to do with politics both within
corporations and with government so let
me turn to the question of when should
you and when shouldn't you contract out
well in the case of government the issue
of accountability and control is one of
the things i think about but i also
think about this in the private sector
in other words if I absolutely must have
minute to minute control of something in
my hands then that may I might not want
to have a purchase or vendor
relationship I would want an
employer-employee relationship okay so
that's so it's when the need for
accountability is extreme this is why I
don't like you know police services that
are contracted not to say security
services can't be contracted but I'm
talking about police services police
services being when somebody can remove
you from freedom or life that's a police
service okay and that's something that
should not be contracted out another
time not to contract out is when
purchasing the service would impair the
organization's capacity and distinctive
competence so what do I mean by that
I've talked about Colombia Colombia does
education and research okay I should not
contract out what I'm doing right now
this is pretty central to what the
University
does right teaching students in a
classroom okay so if somebody in the
school of continuing education gets the
idea you know these internal professors
are too expensive we can get somebody
cheaper from the outside you know that
would be a bad idea because then people
would say well why don't I just go to
the University of Phoenix well I am i
bothering with Columbia the other time
when it's not a good idea to contract
out is when the capacity to do the work
has not yet been developed now sometimes
you do have to contract out to develop
capacity but no that's what you're doing
don't make the mistake of thinking it's
out there when it's not if something
doesn't exist yet whether it's a new
piece of technology or it's a new
service that hasn't been developed yet
you can work with vendors to develop it
but you're working with vendors to
develop it and that and there's nothing
wrong with that but don't mistake that
for buying something off the shelf so
what is the make or buy decision how do
you make it what's in organizations
distinctive competence and why is it
important these are the questions a
contract manager has to ask what is
accountability and why isn't it
important well and why is it important
i'm sorry when shouldn't an organization
outsource these are all questions of
manager has to ask when they're involved
in the contract relationship so let me
talk about them a little bit at a time
here now first the make or buy decision
should we do it in-house to somebody
else do it so here's the factors to ask
yourself how central is the functions of
the organization you also have to ask
how much capital is required okay maybe
we have no choice maybe we can't come up
with the money to do is if we don't get
an outsider involved okay and so you you
make a by decision because you simply
have no capacity to make the thing even
though you'd like to remember a lot of
organizational choices are suboptimal
you have to ask yourself is the capacity
to perform this function common or rare
is it something we need to develop or do
we better have somebody else develop it
as if I spend the time developing this
new capacity in house
let's say I'm the Air Force instead of
contracting with Boeing or locking to
develop that new fighter jet if we
decided to do it in-house would that
make any sense is the Air Force really
about building jets or is it about using
the jets in fighting obviously one is
their distinctive competence the other
isn't can someone else do this better
and cheaper and are they willing to sell
it to us okay one other issue and again
we see this with the Defense Department
all the time is when they have a single
vendor that vendor has a monopoly and
suddenly even though you pay to develop
a thing the price goes through the
ceiling because they know they've got
you okay so part of it is trying to
figure out a way around that which is
very hard to do sometimes organizational
distinctive competence I talked about
this when we talked about organization
theory what does that mean in order for
an organization to survive it has to do
something that nobody else does to get
resources and this comes from Chester
Barnard and Philip cells next to the
great organizational theorist of the
20th century what they said is that the
function of the leader is to look up
into the organization's environment and
see where can we get resources what can
we make it'll get us resources and down
into the organization to develop the
distinctive competence if an
organization doesn't do something that
nobody else does then they don't get
business okay now you could be the only
cappuccino cart on broadway and 110th
Street and that means that's your
distinctive competence and you want to
make sure that you're not contracting
that out okay whatever it is you have to
think about what do we do here that
nobody else does if an organization
gives that away then they find
themselves in trouble and eventually
they go out of business an
organization's distinctive competence
defines what an organization is it says
here's what we are here's what we do
okay this is not to say the distinctive
comptences are static and you know one
of the best examples of its on the board
here IBM invented in many respects the
mask PC you know and they don't make
them anymore they sold the business they
got out of it they found that their
distinctive competence was not in mass
marketing consumer computers they're
still in the server business but they're
not in the PC business okay New York
City's human resources administration
used to deliver all the social services
in New York City now nearly all the
social services in New York City are
delivered by nonprofit organizations in
contract with the the city either the
human resource administration and
Department of homeless services okay or
the children's are the agency for
children's all of these kinds of
organizations evolved over time now one
of the things you have to do when you're
out sources maintain the capacity to
manage the function and this was this
issue of the hollow state if I contract
something out to such a degree that I
have nobody in the organization that
knows what the service looks like
eventually I'm going to lose the
capacity to even manage that service and
so you can have a problem of over
contract let me talk a little bit about
accountability one of the reasons why
the agency for Children Services was
created in New York was that a little
girl was killed because the foster care
parents that were caring for her were
evil people and they killed her and Rudy
Giuliani was mayor then he went in front
of the meeting and said it wasn't our
fault we contracted this out to the
nonprofit guess what nobody cared they
said you're responsible you're the
you're the officer on duty and I think
in the end Rudy understood that was the
case and they created the agency for
Children Services and he brought his old
friends Cappetta to run it and that was
all about accountability so
accountability you know contracting
doesn't change the demand for
accountability and in the private sector
if you're responsible for the production
of a contract
they're telling your boss well it's a
vendor that messed up they don't care
you messed up and so you have to manage
that so accountability is always
important when you're dealing with these
kinds of relationships so management has
to know that they have information on
performance contracting changes the
nature of management influences and
control but it doesn't change the
necessity of control you still have to
understand what's going on so let me
talk a little bit about the future of
contractor first of all you're going to
see more and more of this organizations
are becoming more and more specialized
I'll give you an example of anybody here
working event planning anybody know what
that is event management anybody working
that okay there's there are companies
now that you go to when you have a
conference and they run your event for
you or you have a fundraiser and they
run your event free that's event
planners okay this is a profession that
didn't exist 20 years ago okay but you
can contract out for that and have it
done for you there's almost nothing
that's done in an organization that
isn't done by somebody that you can buy
whether it's accounting services or
bookkeeping or any number of things in
an organization can be contracted out
and you're going to see more and more of
this in part because of the there the
other technological factors that are
contributing to this are and I'll say
this again Communications and
Information the price of communication
and information is getting lower and
lower think about this for a second 20
years ago if you were making a call to
Europe or California you would think oh
it's a long distance call how much does
it cost how many of you think about how
much a phone call costs now before you
make it anybody think about that anymore
okay we have one person left it still
thinks about it okay but that used to
dominate your thinking because it was
expensive same thing with information
you know information is ubiquitous do
you think about how you know every year
computing power gets cheaper and cheaper
and we get
use more and more of it in our daily
lives so that allows us to manage ever
more distant vendors in different kinds
of relationships now very often a
organization decides not to tie up its
capital in having a big warehouse with
supplies for its production they use
adjust in time techniques where they
have fedex deliver it or UPS deliver it
just as they need it and they know it's
coming because it just like you track
you know is my you know Hanukkah or
Christmas present getting to Aunt Mabel
and you're looking on the web to see
well it just made it made it through
Kentucky now it's in Newark just made it
to the Bronx it just got signed in and
aunt Mabel's building okay well the
people that run organizations do this
electronically on everything they order
all the time and some companies have
perfected that into a fine art form well
we're going to see more and more of this
more linking performance management
systems to what contractors do Walmart
does this in everything they purchase
their information system extends all the
way out into Procter & Gamble they know
where every Pete every every tooth every
tooth paste tube that they're buying
they know where it is in a manufacturing
process and where it is until it leaves
their store so obstacles to contracting
are going to be overcome we're going to
see more and more of this as time goes
on